stell dir vor du bist sprachforscherin
spezialisiert auf fremde sprachen seit
tagen bist du unterwegs im urwald
endlich triffst du auf den gesuchten
volksstamm dessen sprache zu erforschen
willst du brauchst ein lager etwas
abseits auf mit kamera und richtmikrofon
beobachtet das geschehen erst aufmerksam
zu sie versteht nur bahnhof
dann aber passiert etwas interessantes
sofort notiert du in der notiz buchcover
gleich haase
doch dann nach einigem überlegen kommen
ihr zweifel könnte der marica war gar
nicht auch unser abendessen gemeint
haben oder auf zur jagd oder heute gibt
es ein gewitter
du kommst zu dem schluss gaga könnte
alles mögliche bedeuten
hasenfuß vielleicht auch affe wäre
möglich angenommen der mann sieht
schlecht
die zweifel daran dass du richtig
verstehst was gemeint ist häufen sich da
kommt ihr eine idee schnell zeichnest du
einen hasen kommst aus seinem versteck
hervor und gehst auf den mann zu du
zeigst ihm deine hasenzeichnungen und
fragst kg er wedelt mit den armen
was hat das nun wieder zu bedeuten ja
oder nein
ratlos kehrst du zu deinem unterschlupf
zurück ist das zuhause mit der eigenen
sprache nicht auch so verstehen wir uns
da immer woher wissen wir eigentlich was
andere meinen wenn sie haase sagen
können wir jemals mit sicherheit wissen
was andere mit ihren worten nein